سيدتي
الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه الموقر انه دواعي
فخري ان اقف هنا ممثل جنوب افريقيا ساتحدث
الان عن النيه الاسرائيليه لارتكاب
الاباده
الجماعيه وفي هذه المرحله
المحكمه
هي تخلص من الادله المتاحه ان هنالك النيه
الاباده الجماعيه ومن اجل فرض التدابير
المؤقته وطبعا هنالك
تقييم
لنيه لارتكاب
الدمار و والمحكمه يمكنها ان تبحث في
هذا من منظور الاجراءات التي وصلت الى
ارتكاب اعمال جبايه
ناهيك واعمال وحشيه ناهيك على الاباده
جماعيه وهذه الاجراءات كلها ترتقي الى
مستوى الاباده الجماعيه سيدتي الرئيسيه
الرئيسه جنوب افريقيا ليست وحدها في لفت
الانتباهي الى الخطاب الاباده الجماعيه
للاسرائيليين ان ما يجري في قطاع غزه يعكس
منظور اباده جماعيه وان هنالك النيه
لتدمير حيوات الشعب الفلسطينيين الشعب
الفلسطيني ان
اسرائيل عندها نيه اباده جماعيه ضد
الفلسطينيين في
غزه وهذا يتجلى من الطريقه التي تشن فيها
اسرائيل عملياتها العسكريه والتي وصفتها
السيده
حسيم لانها عباره هي عباره عن عمل عمليات
ممنهجه فيها تهجير بالجمله لل فلسطينيين
ذهبوا فيها الى
مناطق طرد فيها و
قتلوا وايضا الوضع القائم هو يؤدي الى موت
بطيء نهايه الاقتباس ان اسرائيل ايضا
هنالك
تتبنى نمطا واضحا في استهداف منازل ومساكن
الفلسطينين وبنهم التحتيه
وايضا
القصف
والقنص النساء والرجال في ماكن تواجدهم
وتدمير البنى التحتيه الصحيه وعدم تمكين
وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه قدر كثير يجري وهنالك الان ونحن
نقف هنالك فق 1% من
ال 1% من الشعب في غزه لم
يتم
ايذاؤه منذ السابع من اكتوبر هذين
العنصرين
وحدهما ادله كافيه على نيه الاباده
الجماعيه عند
اسرائيل الموجهه ضد
الشعب الغزي ومع
هذا
هنالك سمه خاصه في هذه القضيه وهي ان
القيادات الاسرائيليه السياسيه وقياداتها
العسكريه ومن يطلعون بمناصب رسميه قاموا
بطريقه ممنهجه وعلانيه في الاعلان انه
انهم لديهم هذه النيه بارتكاب الاباده
الجماعيه وهذه الخطابات وهذه البيانات تم
تكرارها من قبل الجنود على الارض في غزه
وهم يشاركون في تدمير القتل الفلسطيني
وتدمير المادي للبنى التحتيه في غزه و
الان سوف تاليا سوف نتحدث عن عنصر الثالث
ان اسرائيل ونيت في الاباده الجماعيه
متروا في قناعتهم بان العدو هو ليس الجنح
العسكري
لحماس ولا حتى حماس بشكل اعم وانما هو
مضمن في نسيج الحياه ال فلسطينين في غزه
وفي السابع من اكتوبر وفي خطاب متلفز رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتانياهو اعلن
الحرب على غزه واقتبسوا عنه بان اسرائيل
قد بدات
في
تطهير المجتمعات التي تسلل لها
الارهابيين و سيدفع العدو
ثمنا باهضا غير